maire de la garenne colombes dans les
hauts-de-seine philippe juvin c'est
qu'il n'est pas parmi les favoris le
candidat au congrès les républicains
souhaitent tout de même faire entendre
ses idées dans cette campagne ce lundi
22 novembre il est venu échanger avec
une quarantaine de militants dans la
salle des fêtes des gâtines à plaisir je
continue à travailler en ayant des bons
d'achat la fois un homme politique
réelle j'ai même été dix ans député
européen et en même temps j'ai toujours
un métier j'ai des expériences qui me
permettent de savoir prendre des
décisions difficiles dans la salle une
quarantaine de militants pour certains
toujours indécis je suis venu parce que
chez moeurs entendre toutes les
propositions des différents candidats
c'est un homme de conviction c'est
talent qui a tué qui tiendra ses paroles
de france ce matin je l'écouté sur bfm
déjà il sait de quoi il parle
chef des urgences de l'hôpital
georges-pompidou les services publics
lui tiennent à coeur ils nagent à
contre-courant sur la question des
fonctionnaires selon lui il ne faut pas
réduire le nombre d'emplois mais
redistribuer les rôles en diminuant les
postes administratifs et en augmentant
les postes en contact avec le public je
pense que la droite
doit être une droite qui réfléchit à des
questions qui ne sont pas les siennes
habituellement la question des services
publics moi je suis pour la droite des
services publics je pense que le service
public c'est indispensable
à ce que tout le monde soit pareillement
traité sur le territoire et parce que
c'est un élément de prospérité quand
vous avez l'école qui fonctionne vous
avez des ingénieurs et des scientifiques
d'un temps plus tard face à philippe
juvin quatre autres candidats michel
barnier xavier bertrand eric ciotti et
valérie pécresse on est honnêtement dans
un flou artistique chez nous et l'air
parce qu'on n'a pas encore de candidat
mais quand la dynamique va être lancé je
pense qu'on va retrouver notre électorat
qui nous a fait gagner jusqu'à
maintenant
les adhérents du parti les républicains
devront départager les cinq candidats
lors d'un congrès en ligne du 1er au 4
décembre